Matt it's Ross Tucker filling in for Dan
really appreciate the time
congratulations man what what's the
first thing you did with your medal
thank you very much it was a it was a
real thrill I knew I was a bit out of
contention and knew I needed a sundae
put together 63 on Sunday was just
amazing so I've been just wearing the
medal proudly swept into the hole do a
lot of fun was it a tough decision to go
Matt I mean did you did you know right
away yeah I want to go or did you debate
it know I'm such a famous for such a fan
of Olympics outside chance of qualifying
and just barely snuck into the top 15 in
the world which is qualified me to make
the Olympics and when my name was called
to represent Team USA I was like I had
fingers crossed that had worked out what
an amazing experience it was down here
in Rio came down and like the media gave
gave this place a pretty bad rap came
down and just just could not have had a
better more fun experience what's been
the best part outside of actual you know
the playing and winning the bronze we
went to a lot of the sports and like I
said I'm on three big sports junkie and
watching Phelps is my first first
filming me that I've been to Washington
felt Tuesday night win gold and the 200
butterflies just so inspiring to see him
do his thing it's just awesome so
Jackson Steven Johnson won a bronze
medal match I actually really enjoyed
watching badminton just amazing rallies
I was blown away with the reaction time
to speed and the coordination does get
better and I'm such a ping-pong fan what
the table tennis and I always was blown
away by how quickly those guys move
around and fly it's just it was awesome
is there any sport mat that you came
away thinking man I kind of want to try
it I think I could be pretty good at
that one too
I stayed with some friends at the PGA
Championship their son and track and
field guy and he says the javelin so a
couple weeks ago and I had had my eye
crack at tossing the javelin and that's
uh that was good father I was nowhere
near what a good high school throw was
soon I don't think they were olympian
was but I'm now heading home and I'm
actually I can't wait to watch the
Olympic on TV and check all the
different sports talk with Matt Kuchar
the golfer for the USA who won the
bronze medal with an unbelievable round
on Sunday Matt that's your best round
since when because I'm not great with
memory of of all the lower rounds that
I've shot but certainly in that
situation be able to pull off a great
number I'll tell you there are a lot of
times where I'm a handful of shots back
and you try to play a little bit more
aggressively you try to see if you can
win and you don't always get to pull off
a 63 and to be able to do it in such a
cool stage at the Olympics felt like
making an Olympic charge on Sunday it's
just an amazing feeling met will you
definitely participate do you think in
2020
I fear hope I sure hope to qualify and
golf going to Tokyo at the Olympics in
2020 but certainly a goal goal of mine
and I think after this Olympics you'll
see you know all the golfers get really
excited to try qualify for 2020 in Tokyo
yeah I was gonna ask you do you think
more guys will participate in 2020 Oh
without a doubt
there is a huge successes this Olympics
this one went really really well it's
great to see henrik stenson battled out
with Justin Rose Henrik has just been on
such a good formula they're great for
analyst Phil Mickelson and the British
Open and then to battle down with Justin
and have kind of tossed my hat and the
contention for gold now for a little bit
but it was just a little bit
too far back but I think that's the same
went over so well but we'll have
everybody fighting for a spot from 2020
so what do you think you're gonna do
Matt with with the metal now you're
gonna put it on the side of your hat are
you going to wear it around your neck or
what are you gonna do with it no not
real sure what's going to happen where
it's going to go it's certainly going to
stay around my neck for a while my necks
getting a good workout metal is pretty
heavy but uh you know couldn't be
prouder to show it off III gotta say I
was out there and knew that I was in
contention to really earn a metal amount
of pride that I felt for myself for my
country for USA it's just an amazing
ability to be part of the Olympics you
wanted to qualify other than your
country did bonus on top to be able to
earn a medal and the [ __ ] out of her
mental of going to do the medal ceremony
I didn't present you but not always just
just an amazing feeling
man congratulations thanks so much for
the time
hi you got me on absolutely there is
Matt Kuchar us a golfer won the bronze
medal the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience